do you like our spectrum videos if so we
actually made a game where you can play
at home with your friends and family we
made a kickstarter and if you want to go
check it out and support it that would
be amazing you can actually even have
maybe one of your prompts be a part of
the game like
clothes and makeup have no gender what
do you think
do they
i don't know
we're gonna find out
and then i'm also like a gym rat so
another day it could be just like we hit
legs we get chipotle yeah i don't work
out too much
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm tyler i'm 18 from colorado i'm a
summer camp instructor and a script
writer i think my style is kind of a
mixture between like emo um kind of my
own clothing that i've made um i think
there's gonna be a jump um in fashion
really soon with like this casual cowboy
thing so you know i have i have this
right here and and on the back too i
love girls that like have their own
style you know that i can look at them
be like i have not seen that before or
even just a piece that i haven't seen
before it's awesome to see girls kind of
adopt their own fashion sense
[Music]
okay
um number one uh what was the decision
behind the cowboy i used to be a
horse girl so i decided to wear the
cowboy boots because it goes like with
my old horse girl self and my new style
which is more like gothic tell me like
if i were to take you out on a date what
would you want to do maybe we can go
like vintage shopping and i can pick out
an outfit for you and you can pick out
an outfit for me i love it that's a
great answer i'm over here telling
people to take note on that one right
there uh number two what was the
decision behind the shoes today i like
square boots a lot so i thought it would
give me a little 70s vibes with the
flare pants yeah what would you do out
on a date with me um to be honest i'm
pretty impulsive so i love planning on
the spot on my free time i like driving
around listening to music so that has to
be incorporated into the uh plan for
sure uh number three i like to stand out
like with little pieces when it comes to
my outfit because i'm very into like
like little vintage details and
everything so if we were going on our
first day we would most likely be going
to a drive-in because that's like one of
the main things that i like to do
awesome these are my sparkly stumpers
um they're my favorite shoes i wear them
too much probably and you can pick
people with them and dance in them and
do a lot of things that's awesome i
would want to go to a bookstore and we
could pick up books for each other maybe
make playlists for each other
i like that one what would you put on my
playlist
french music french music yeah that's
the wild card can you speak any french
actually i like your outfit is chador
tatuni um i'm pretty sure that's how you
pronounce it
sorry if it's not to people watching um
the starlaced converse i like it i like
it it's very summer camp instructor
vibes i like when my outfit has like two
matching colors or like two main point
colors so it was brown first and then i
needed some green magic so they do work
for my perfect birthday i really like
picnics so i would prefer like an
evening picnic maybe like three or five
p.m
okay number six
yeah these are my dogs but they make me
feel really powerful and like taller
than everyone and i can step on someone
and then also i don't know i feel like
it attracts like skater boys and i don't
know i think that's like kind of helpful
for me me and you baby we can stomp on
people together
what's your ideal date um i'm a very
like active person so i think they're
really fun if we could go like surfing
together or snowboarding even i've never
gone and then i'm also like a gym rat so
another day it could be just like we hit
legs we get chipotle i don't know up to
you yeah i don't work out too much um
i'll try we'll definitely try that
okay um
i'm going to have to eliminate four
um i'm excited to see you now sorry
sadly show me your face
oh my god eliminate me for my shoes
it's just not the shoes not the shoes
not the sparkly stuff
thank you sorry i like to fit a lot yeah
you should
[Music]
okay
i was just gonna ask you guys kind of
when you're looking for someone to date
uh what do you look for in a guy i don't
know i like when a guy is like confident
i do like when a guy can like pull off
like feminine clothing i think that's
really attractive that's like my
favorite part of fashion is watching
people just absolutely break what
everyone else thinks is fashion you know
i think that's the coolest part you know
um number two uh what do you look for in
a guy you know i always like trying
different clothing styles and you know
experimenting with that so if i can find
someone who's into that too then you
know best of both worlds for the both of
us uh number three first and foremost i
just want to make sure that they're
confident and everything and that
they're not afraid to speak their mind
and when it comes to fashion as well i
love it when they express themselves in
a different level that fights too much
like a deep darker emotion i like to
look for their smile first i feel like
when someone has a really pretty smile
like you can tell they're like a nice
person i know it's like kind of like
weird but i love when guys are overalls
i don't know why but that's like so
attractive to me okay good i like that
yeah
[Music]
i'm going to have to eliminate number
three
oh sorry thank you hug thank you i'm
sorry
that's so
i love this if i looked at the whole fit
with like everything then then i would
definitely i would have definitely let
you stay longer yeah i love your fit i
love the little
like strings on your chest
[Laughter]
definitely sad that i had to make that
elimination she's very cute
oh
um okay
i think
i'm gonna have to eliminate number three
[Music]
thank you i love your necklace does it
connect yeah
it hasn't i could have taken one
[Music]
all right
number one if i was
having a bad day just not really feeling
that whoa how would you
come up and interact with me
um i would probably ask you like what's
wrong like why are you feeling this way
and then depending how you react i would
ask if you'd want to be left alone but
if like you wanted me to talk to you
like help you feel a little
yeah that's good i like the the the
that crack a better
between there i'm i'm very into like
gift giving so i'd probably make you a
little something and like put it on like
the counter and be like oh like here you
go next cheer you up a little gift
basket of some sort um i start with a
peace offering so maybe like some coffee
if i have it maybe some sushi and then
personally like my love language is
physical touch so like i always like
want to like cuddle with someone or like
watching movies and stuff and just like
i don't know i love like
i'll be the big spoon too that's cool
with me
um so
then i have to eliminate number two
[Music]
this necklace i couldn't like take my
eyes off thank you i love the sunglasses
super cute shoes nice tattoos nice these
two are catches
you got a good lineup
that's good
dad i'm gonna have to take a second to
think on this one oh this is so hard
um
[Music]
i think i'm going to
have to eliminate
number two
this is not a decision that i wanted to
make
oh i'm so sorry i love your outfit thank
you i love your pearls thank you so much
yes sir
exactly when i say casual cowboy this is
this is the future of fashion right here
we need a post together this is this is
we are we're icons together
actually all of us will be going on the
date without you yeah
[Music]
you